[Music]
that is huge Ackman singing along to
pings cover of a million dreams from his
musical the greatest showman it's all
part of the upcoming reimagined
soundtrack and pika is one of many
artists who sings on it including Kelly
Clarkson Missy Elliott and in this
absolutely adorable behind the scenes
footage of Pink Zone seven-year-old
daughter Willow
[Music]
the look of pride from pink is second
only to the way willow
lovingly gazes at her mom turns singing
coach the greatest showmen reimagined is
out November the 16th and peak says it
is their favorite movie at home I grew
up listening to Annie and no one has
done this for me for my heart since I
was a little girl and to have her
finally have something like this how
proud of your mommy are you this
precious mother-daughter duo has been
stealing our hearts for years they would
like to know what you thought of mommy's
performance today and Elyse great it was
good like like awesome good or like kind
of good awesome it's clear Pink's
priority has always been to cultivate
willows confidence and independence
she's not very impressed by me which I
like we hear you right you can do it
yourself why would you be impressed I
think you're fun
I'm sorry cuz you're fun I'm glad I had
you
[Music]
[Applause]